chào các
bạn Hôm nay chúng ta học cái bài về cái
thiết lập mặc
định trước khi chúng ta soạn thảo một
văn bản thì thiết lập đó bao gồm thứ
nhất là chúng ta sẽ chọn đơn vị đo
lường đơng vị đau lượng này nó thể hiện
cái dễ thấy nhất là trên kích
thước chúng ta xác định lề và kích cỡ
của các đối
tượng TP thứ hai là chúng ta đặt lề cho
văn bản và sau đó chúng ta chọn kích cỡ
giấy thao Tảo thứ ba là chúng ta chọn
Phong chữ kích cỡ và định dạng khoảng
cách và tất cả những cái định dạng này
đều là mặc định và bây giờ chúng ta thực
hiện thao tác đầu tiên là chọn đơn vị đo
lượng chúng ta vào thẻ file chọn
option Sau đó chúng ta chọn thẻ Advance
chúng ta r chuột qua bên phải chúng ta
dùng kéo thanh cuộng xuống chúng ta tìm
đến cái mục đây s ma in unit Off và
chúng ta đổi đơn vị đo lượng ở đây có
nhiều cái đơn vị đo lượng mặc định là in
chúng ta có thể chọn cm coi hay mm Vân
Vân ở đây mình sẽ chọn là
Cm rồi ok đó là xong cái thao tác là
chọn đơn vị đo lượt Để chúng ta qu con
sát trên này đơn vị này là
Cm rồi nội dung thứ hai đó là đặt lề cho
văn bản và kích cờ của tră giấy thì
chúng ta sẽ vào
layout trong cái khung pay setup chúng
ta nhấp vào nút này ra chuột đến nó có
chữ là pay setup nhấp chuột vào chúng
chấ chọn cái thẻ maging để đặt lề to bu
là lề định và lề đại
left là Lê trái và lề phải là lề phải và
theo quy định của soạn thảo văn bản hình
chính
thì lề đỉnh lề đáy thì chúng ta có thể
dùng là đến 2 đến 2.5 cm ở đây chúng ta
dùng
2 lề trái thì 2.5 đến 3 thì chúng ta sẽ
dùng là 3 và L phải tương tự chúng ta
chọn 2 như vậy ngy tắc dễ nhớ nhất khi
chúng ta đặt lề cho một văn bản Hà chính
đó là 2 2 3
2 tiếp tục chúng ta sẽ chọn là payer để
xác định kích cỡ của trong giấy và trong
soá thảo văn bản hành chính thì paper
side
cũng là mặc định có một cái mặc định của
nó t theo quy định của nó là kích cỡ A4
rồi chúng ta nhắp chọn A4 Sau đó chúng
ta chọn Ok Tuy nhiên để nó là những cái
thông tin này nó là mặt định thì chúng
ta chọn lên là set add default thiết lập
mặc định nhấp
vào và nó hỏi bạn muốn thiết lập mặc
định hay không thì chúng ta chọn yes
à xong đó là thao tác đặt lề và kích cỡ
trang giấy mặc định thao tác thứ ba là
chọn Phong chữ kích cỡ và định dạng
khoảng cách dòng khoảng cách đoạn thì
chúng ta sẽ vào thẻ
home và trong cái khung Style chúng ta
tìm đến cái cái Style có tên là nmo và
trong trường hợp này nó hiển thị sẵn này
một số trường hợp nó không có thì chúng
ta sẽ nhấp vào nút Mall này để chúng ta
tìm Mall này nhấp vào đây chúng ta tìm à
tìm chúng ta tìm danh sắt chế này chắc
chắn nó sẽ có vì đây là cái Style cơ bản
trong gu rồi chúng ta tìm thấy thì chúng
ta nhắc phải chuột vào nmo chúng ta chọn
modify tiếp tục à tên và thuộc tính
Style Follow này chúng ta để ý Vậy chúng
ta chỉ thao tác trên thuộc tính
formatting là định dạng thứ nhất là
phong chữ chúng ta chọn kích cỡ tin
Roman cũng theo quy định của văn bản
hình chính kết Cỡ 12 hoặc
13 và màu sắc thì chúng ta chọn màu auto
có nghĩa là màu đen chúng ta muốn định
dạng khoảng cách dòng khoảng cách đoạn
thì chúng ta vào
format chọn
paragraph và cái mục spacing là khoảng
cách đoạn before after Before là khoảng
cách trước đoạn văn after là khoảng cách
sau phía sau đón văng đây phía trước là
đây phía sau đây và bây giờ chúng ta có
thể thay đổi cái này ví dụ Chúng ta muốn
là before và after đều 6pt thì chúng ta
chọn 6pt nhấp vào các nút tăng giảm ở
đây 6pt là tương đương với 1/2
dòng đó là khoảng cách giữa các đoạn
tiếp tục là khoảng cách giữa các dòng
trong một đoạn thì chúng ta sẽ thao tác
trên thộc tính là l spacing và multiple
là 1,08 có nghĩa là Thông thường thì mặc
định là 1 thôi là khoảng cách đơn chúng
ta muốn tăng khoảng cách lên thì chúng
ta sẽ nhập vào là 1,2 1,3 1,4 gì đó Ở
đây mình sẽ nhập là 1,1 rồi Kết thúc thì
chúng ta lại chọn Ok và chúng ta muốn
những cái thiết lập này là cho những cái
file word sau đó tức là thiết lập mặc
định thì chúng ta sẽ chọn cái tùy chọn
này nè Đó là new document b on play có
nghĩa là cái tài liệu mới á là nó cũng
dựa trên cái mẫu này nha và chúng ta
chọn Ok để kết thúc và đó là ba cái bước
ba cái thiết lập mặc
định cơ bản trong trong guộc mà chúng ta
cần phải phải lưu ý khi bắt đầu tràn
Thảo có nghĩa là chúng ta cài đặt vuộc
xong thì chúng ta sẽ làm cái này ha rồi
đến đây là kết thúc chào các bạn